you know given everything that's
happening right now a lot of people
are turning to comfort food to ease
their anxiety
it's a natural thing to do well guess
what one of our sponsors is here
to make that process even easier
life has been pretty stressful lately
you're bored
anxious and scared and you're stress
eating more than ever
don't worry applebee's has got your back
introducing the applebee's stress eaters
combo meal
a giant selection of random foods
delivered to your door
that you can snack on all day long while
the world falls apart
each stress eater's combo meal includes
two pizza slices
three hershey's kisses a hard-boiled egg
five loose almonds
half a bag of potato chips three chicken
nuggets half a tangerine
a mini bottle of jack daniels a bunch of
those laughing cow cheese wedges the
butt end of a salami six twizzlers and a
plastic spoon with a big mound of peanut
butter on it
and that's just the first layer
applebee's stress eaters combo meal
the perfect way to bridge the gap
between lunch and second lunch